I gave up my leg for that catch. It was a catch
We should have four wins
Hmm
Screw it. It's time I take this to Challenge Court!
ALL RISE! ...or kneel...or
Yeah, we don't need to go there. OK, proceed.
Receivers and corners of the jury, Exhibit A
Now does Mr. Miller ever gain full control
of the football?
(Gasp)
OK now technically the rule states that in order...
for a catch you need a football move...
But now they changed...
Needs to be two feet in bounds...
That's a good question!
What is the ground?
In conclusion he never became a runner, so
therefore not a catch
Mannn, what the f--k does that mean?
I get it, Dez.
Now I'm not some hotshot TV ref
I'm a man of the people
So my first witness is...100 guys at a bar!
Gentlemen, was that a catch?
Hell yeah that's a catch!
IF THE BALL DOES NOT FALL,
CATCH IS THE CALL!
Jury, have you come to a decision?
Yeah, we've decided we have, uh, no idea
what a catch is
Well in that case the NFL defaults to the less
fun option, no catch!
All right next up, Jerry Jones for TREASON
You are sentenced to watch football with
those guys
NOOO!
BOOO! JERRY JONES! JERRY JONES!